hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to getting over it
I have calmed down I've relaxed I I've
tried very hard to collectively think
about what I've learned from the last
one and also take that into
consideration for what I'm doing
in the next round so I just got to get
up over these goddamn umbrellas but
thankfully you know I should be grateful
for the things I have
instead of like wondering what I don't
have is a will to live
oh please just oh I should be grateful
for what I have not grateful for what I
don't have any loss progress is a
opportunity to succeed I don't like you
okay
no no no no alright marmolada marmolada
mama lied ooh mama dada mama lied did
mama dada okay not wait they're just
scraping the tippy-top e whoa that was a
quick thrust buddy boo okay set me down
there's a time for quiet contemplation
and then there's a time for I know I'm
over here now on text it's tempting to
make friendly content that's gentle that
lets you churn through it but not earn
it
why make something demanding if it just
gets piled up in the landfill filed in
with the bland things okay alright
is this a way that I'm supposed to go
know so I have no rainbow head to eyes
no tears
Jon Vance Chaney
[Music]
[Applause]
if I lose everything
I will kill again no no no no no no not
what I wanted no not what I wanted okay
so I have to go over there with the
boxes that's a definite yes oh my god oh
my god I am gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna [ __ ] die no no no no stop what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing with your life me what am
i doing with my life I could be doing
anything
[Music]
why why what no-no-no cannot now believe
that you will ever feel better but this
is not true you're sure to be happy
again and knowing this truly believing
it will make you less miserable now
Abraham Lincoln
[Music]
I'm gonna die I am going to die here I
am going to die I am going to die this
game will kill me this game
I'm not joking this game will kill me
you've done this part before you know
it's possible just do what you did the
fit oh [ __ ] off with you you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] off I know I've done this part
before one small step back one small
step back I know it's so [ __ ] just
gently like a [ __ ] butterfly no no
there we go there we go okay good news
we've officially made it back to where
we were just a little bit ago no that's
not how we do why why why I don't
understand you because it changes
position based on where the camera goes
to so if the camera moves your mouse
moves to I can hold my mouse completely
still
if the Matt if the camera is moving then
I'm moving you know you didn't have to
make this game developer you did not
have to make this game why no that's
exactly how I fell down last time you
will why are you doing that damn you oh
[ __ ]
I made it not out of choice but out of
necessity okay stop okay
so somewhere there's a safe place to
drop here very see I didn't move my
mouse at all
that was the camera moving whoa
okay I see it okay
I see it okay so what I got to do is
angle push off
okay all right okay
I never thought I'd get back to this
point so you know they got something
there's something to that whole stick
about whatever the Frick they were
talking about okay
all right everyone please a moment of
silence this moment this might be the
most important maneuver of my life when
games when used they want a lot Oh
daunting taunting you resetting and
delaying your players played stoic Lee
now everyone's turned off by that they
want to burn through it quickly a quick
fix for the fickle some tricks for the
cliques of the feckless but that's not
you you're an acrobat you could swallow
a baseball bat what what are you talking
about I don't want to swallow a baseball
bat I don't even want to swallow this
[ __ ] game so I think I think that oh
no no stop stop stop stop stop stop
holy God so the answer is I have to
swing I can't push off because of the
angle of this chair I have to swing I
have to do a swing launch into that
[Music]
shut up moon why why why why why I can
launch myself a thousand miles when I
don't want to but when I want to launch
myself nothing no no oh no I can't do it
I can't be raised again I cannot do it I
can't I can't do it I'm gonna do it
I'm the back in the next episode thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you
[Music]